hey everyone this is kevin from the
chess website calm today we're going to
be going over a very special game
between bot and Vic and Capablanca now
many of you are probably familiar with
Capablanca one of the most famous chess
players of all time what you may not
know is button Vic was actually a pretty
awesome chess player in his own right
capablanca was the world champion for
about 6 years
bhana Vic was the world champion for
about twice that long until died he was
the world champion for 13 years so while
you may look at this and say you know
this is just some amateur playing kappa
blanka do not think that at all this is
actually one of the greatest chess minds
that you may not have heard of playing
capablanca so in this particular game we
have bought viniq versus Kappa Lanka but
viniq is going to be playing the white
pieces and capablanca is going to be
playing the black pieces this game
starts out with the nimzo-indian defense
if you're not too familiar with it I
definitely recommend you watching a
video on it but it starts out with pawn
to d4 Knight f6 pawn to c4 punny six
Knight to c3 and then the bishops going
to come down to b4 now nowadays as far
as White's concern white really doesn't
like to play this quite often a lot of
times at the top level play you won't
see white play this simply because he's
going to have a double pawn if black so
chooses opposite he can take here on c3
and after the pawn takes here on c3 he's
going to have doubled pawns on this
e-file now keep in mind back in the day
I mean this was played in the late 1930s
they didn't quite have all of the
opening theory that we have today so as
we go along keep in mind that some of
the moves that you'll see in this game
are not quite what they played back in
the day in my opinion they were much
better chess players just all around
they just kind of played by instinct and
feel they didn't have hundreds of years
of chess to kind of go through and they
didn't have computer engines to run all
this analysis on they just kind of
played by gut which is kind of why I
enjoy studying these old games but from
here white plays pawn to e3 pretty
standard movement from here black plays
a move that it obviously I don't
recommend because as far
is what we know is opening theory it's
just not that greenie plays pawn to d5
now why is this not really that great of
a move because really by playing Bishop
down to before and just offering up this
exchange here on c3 obviously early on a
game as far as you know Grandmaster
level you typically don't want to
exchange your bishop pair early on even
for a knight even though they are both
three points typically you don't see
bishops coming off the boy this early
but the only reason you would exchange
this bishop here on b4 for this knight
on c3 is because you could give white
double pawns here by bringing your pawn
to d5 yes it does attack the center of
the board but at any time white can
recapture here on d5 and why it's not
going to have doubled pawns anymore so
just keep this in mind
capablanca obviously a very fantastic
chess player but in this case his
opening theory it could have been a
little better he could have Castle
kingside which is typically what you see
nowadays in the nimzo-indian defense
from here why it's going to play pawn to
a3 keep in mind black really has two
options here one he can go ahead and
capture here on c3 or he can kick his
Bishop back to e7 or f8 obviously if he
tries to come back to a5 then white can
just start marching at the board to b4
and then the bishops going to be trapped
right here obviously Capablanca saw this
and he realizes he can say you know what
I can go ahead and move my bishop back
or I can go ahead and exchange in this
case he decided to go ahead and exchange
on c3 after the pawn recaptures on c3
kappa blanka now plays pawn to c5 now
this is a pretty aggressive move you
know trying to attack the center of the
board it's questionable if this was the
best play in this situation keep in mind
as we talked about before pawn on c4
really wants to get off the board
obviously he does have doubled pawns
here so he's going to recapture right
here
now from here blacks going to recapture
with d5 and this is pretty good for
black obviously he has center control
here with his pawn here on c5 and d5 and
at the same time he's putting a lot of
pressure on white sinner or white really
has this one pawn on d4 really attacking
the center of the board
but viniq now played
shift to d3 again simple development
move trying to control these light
scores on the board at the same time
getting ready to castle on the kingside
now keep in mind I see this mistake a
lot from black players this pawn here on
c5 is really doing a good job of
defending and attacking the center of
the board now a lot of times people come
down and just play pawn to c4 trying to
attack this Bishop and just move them
off the bishop really doesn't matter he
can come back to you know c2 if he wants
to kick them back the pawn on d5 is
actually right now doing a lot more than
if it came down to c4 it's not really
controlling the center as much as it
would be as if it's on c5 so keep that
in mind if you're sitting there and
you're like you know automatically I
would just play pawn to c4 because it
would kick that Bishop back well yes it
would kick him back but really you still
don't have that control that you would
if you kept it here on c5 now from here
black decided to castle on the King side
again anytime at the beginning of a game
you obviously want to do two things you
want to develop pieces you want to try
to maintain center control and you
obviously want to castle your King so
that he has King side safety many times
you'll see you know crazy exchanges or
sacrifices typically if your opponent
does not have his King castled and then
you just can ferociously attack your
opponent's King obviously Grand Master
play a lot of times you'll just see the
king castle as soon as you can so from
here White's going to play Knight to e2
and I want to talk about this because
it's very important a lot of times most
people just automatically will play
Knight to f3 but keep in mind in chess
it's not about what you should typically
do all the time a lot of times you have
to look at this the situation look at
the board and then look at what your
opponent wants to do in this case this
night here on f6 eventually he would
really like to come to this
efore Square this is a great outpost for
black and because of that black will
eventually like to trade off these light
score bishops he may try to bring his
pawn to b6 and then try to bring his
Bishop to a6 try to exchange off these
bishops once he does that this square
here on e4 becomes a very very powerful
outpost for the night
now if white were to come and play
Knight to f3 and he really has no
defense for the square here on e4 and
this Knight is not really doing anything
right away now keep in mind this Knight
can get involved into the game but he
can also get involved into the game if
he is on e to right away the good thing
about this Knight here on e too is white
later on can play pawn to f3 again this
pawn here on f3 is going to add a little
bit more defense on this efore square
and at the same time if pawn ever wants
to thrust forward with E 4 it'll have a
an extra defender and attacker here on
the f3 square so keep in mind that's why
he did play the Knight to e2 also keep
in mind if he did play you know let's
say Knight to f3 right away now the pawn
could come you know to c4 as we talked
about in this Bishop would have to move
and then Black has a lot more counter
play he can now really start to to aim
here on this efore Square from his
knight
so once you see this Knight to e2 that's
exactly why you saw it here from from
here black decided to play pawn to b6
again probably getting ready to bring
his Bishop into the game as if you've
seen any of my videos you know that the
light square bishop for white early on
in the game is a lot more powerful
typically it is down on this f7 square
at the same time it does i down on this
h7 squared which is probably the second
biggest weakness that Black has
especially if he does castle on the King
side so typically the dark square bishop
for white and the light square bishop
for black are typically the weakest
bishop so early on if you can exchange
those off it is equal material but
typically most players will try to do
that in this case that's exactly what
black's going to do by bringing his
bishop down to a6
so from here White's going to castle on
the king size we talked about you
obviously want to castle for King side
safety and then here bishops going to
bring his Bishop to a6 getting ready to
exchange now this is very important a
lot of times you can decide since
bishops here on a6 is looking to you
know come down and trade off bishops you
can either try to develop another piece
knowing that he can come down and
capture on d3 knowing that you can
recapture on d3 or you can go ahead and
speak with your bishop on a6 knowing
that his night is going to recapture on
a6 now why decided to go ahead and
capture here on a6 only because you knew
once the night came to a6 the night's
not really going anywhere so he's gonna
actually have to end up losing a tempo
before he really gets his night into the
game obviously you never want to have
your night on the rim you may have heard
the saying a night on the rim is dim so
he knows that this night is going to
have to move more than once before you
can really get into the game so he
decides to go ahead and move his Bishop
to a6 in exchange I was off again you
could see this Knight come to c7 from
here trying to really eye down on this B
5 square if we really wants to get
involved into the Kings side he could
come over here to e6 where he could
always come back to b8 he could kind of
make his way down the board to an
outpost that he kind of creates later on
into the game next move from White was
Bishop to b2 simple development move now
keep in mind you know we are trying to
analyze this game so even though one
side one I don't want to look at and say
every move that they played was exactly
correct you know even though they are
grandmasters we definitely can run their
games who do engines very powerful
engines and see you know a few did two
nuances that they could have done a
little bit better I personally think
that bringing the pawn to a4 here and
then bringing the bishop to a3 is a much
better play for white just because he
can really he's already attacking and
defending this put this square here on
b4 - now attacking and defending this
square here on b5 and at the same time
getting his Bishop a little more active
on the a3 Square eyeing down on this a3
- let's say FA diagonal here it's going
to be a little bit better than his
Bishop here on b2 and this kind of plays
out in the game this Bishop here on b2
is just kind of hanging out most of the
game so although in the long run it
wasn't too bad I do feel like in this
situation he probably should have played
a 4 right away and then played his
Bishop to a3 but nonetheless the Queen
is now going to come to d7 now keep in
mind you always want to connect your
rooks on the back row first a lot of
things I always tell people is you want
to dominate the center of the board you
want
then develop your pieces obviously those
kind of coincide together you want to
use your minor pieces to dominate the
center board with your pawns and then
you want to connect your rooks rooks
always do well connected just because I
kind of help each other out but at the
same time they can kind of slide back
and forth and try to control those open
and semi open files so from here black
plays Queen to d7 as we talked about and
if you look at all the squares he can
come to obviously he can come on this
back row but he kind of wants to give it
off that it can come to c7 he can come
to d6 and he can come to e7 if we kind
of look at all those moves d7 is really
the best place that he can really hit as
many squares as possible the Queen much
like any other piece you know Bishop has
no power if it has no moves same with
the Queen the Queen can pretty much move
anywhere he wants to - a knight move but
if he doesn't have the squares to move
to he's useless so you usually want to
get your Queen into place where he can
move as many places as possible and
that's exactly what Queen to d7 does in
this case he has the most options
possible moving around the board so from
here the pawns going to come to a4 again
he really wants to put pressure on this
b5 square obviously now you can move
this Queen where he wants to and now the
black is going to play rook to e8 now
this is up for debated this is a great
move I think it's great move just
because you want to get your rooks on
semi-open file send me open files
meaning there's one pawn not two pawns
you know if there's no pawn at all
that's completely open file so I think
this is a fantastic move by black here
bringing his rook to e8 as we talked
about just a minute ago from black white
also realizes that he needs to connect
his rook and in the same fashion he also
wants to get his Queen in a spot where
he can attack and defend the most
squares on the board and that place
right now is going to be Queen to d3
really centralizing his queen getting it
involved into the game now the next move
from black is probably the biggest
question mark I have from Kappa black
and it kind of comes back to what we
talked about before and black plays pawn
to c4 he does this for two reason one he
tries to kick off this Queen here on d3
but he really has this idea of bringing
his knight to b8
then see six back to a five and then
down to be three now this is all good in
theory obviously anytime you play chess
you want to have a game plan you don't
just want to sporadically go in and no
matter what goes on you have no game
plan obviously your game plan is going
to change depending on what your
opponent does but keep in mind that your
game plan I think it's a little tough if
your game plan involves moving one piece
you know four or five different squares
also this again this move here on pawn
to c4 it really starts to take away the
center control that black has you know
his his pawn here on c5 is doing really
well just kind of hanging out there when
he brings it down to c4 yes it does kick
this Queen back but it really doesn't do
much more than that besides bring this
outpost to b3 but this outpost on b3 is
very very far away from the king
obviously if you have an outpost you'd
really like it closer to your opponent's
king so keep that in mind yes this is an
outpost here on b3 but it's not nearly
as powerful you know if there was a
great outpost here on e4 that black
could make so just keep that in mind as
we go throughout this game so from here
White has to kick his queen back
obviously he is under attack here and
then black starts his mission again we
already talked about he really wants to
get his Knight down to b3 and he's just
going to let you know white just
continue with his game plan and what's
going to start to attack the king side
he realizes that black has this
initiative to try to do something on the
Queen side even though there's nothing
to attack on the Queen side when white
realizes that to win the game you have
to attack the King so that's kind of
what he does so he now plays rook to e1
obviously getting ready to just crash on
the King side and blacks can continue on
the board Knight to c6
now the Knights going to come here to g3
and this is very powerful move because
he's really getting ready to attack this
e4 square again maintaining center
control is very huge that's kind of why
he brought this rook to e1 he can kind
of push this pawn forward and bring his
knight to g3 this pawn that has two
extra defenders he now has this rook and
he has this knight here on G 3 so again
it's blacks movies and continue with his
game
playing before and now the pawns going
to come to f3 as we talked about before
not only is this protecting this efore
Square very powerful but at the same
fashion we now have an extra defender on
this efore pawn if we very push it up
forward which bottom Vic is going to do
very closely from here so from here
black now plays Knight to b3 again he's
reached this outpost move not quite sure
it's the best move well obviously in
this case it may be but as far as the
initial plan in general it does have an
outpost knee does allow you know black
to come in and take this pawn on a4 but
why it's not really you know trying to
hold on to this pawn on a4 he's trying
to attack this King here on g8 so from
here White's now kind of play pawn to e4
again pawns are meant to be pushed and
you can't push pawns until they can get
past the center so that's what white
knows here he has to dominate the center
of the board and then he can start
pushing pawns forward now capablanca
right away doesn't really see a huge
danger he's easy as you know pretty good
center control here he does have a rook
on EA you know protecting this he does
have a night here on f6 controlling some
of the light squares on the board so
he's going to go ahead and he's going to
go ahead and start taking material so
you know queen 2a for blacks now up and
material the only problem is white now
starts to you know attack more on the
center so he plays pawn to e5 now one of
the things that white has to do this is
something that you always have to do in
your game if you have a lot of dynamic
you know play and you have you know
Queens and Brooks really trying to
attack your opponent you need to open
lines up you really if the board is
completely you know clustered and it's
really blocked
you know Queens and rooks aren't going
to do anything so if you really want to
have a strong attack one of the best
ways you can do this is by opening up
line so white knew this in this case
since that's why I bought the big plate
pawn to e5 now from here the Knights
going to move to d7 again obviously he
does have to move here and now the
Queen's going to come to f2 now this is
a fantastic move because he knows he has
to get the Queen into the game and he's
it's kind of a waiting movement at the
same
I'm he's getting he's just completely
giving up on the queenside he's putting
all his eggs in one piece and in one
basket he's really trying to eye down on
the black King here on g8 now my opinion
capablanca probably still felt like he
had you know control this game he was up
in material the same fashion there's no
real clear advantage as far as how
White's going to capitalize on the
center control that he has yes he does
have a lot of pieces on the kingside but
it really takes the phenomenal game plan
to figure out how he's going to actually
checkmate this king here on g8 and
obviously this coin here on a4 can get
back into the action if he wants to and
at the same token this Bishop here on b2
isn't doing anything and it's going to
be really hard for him to get into the
action so I'm sure black felt pretty
comfortable here you play pawn to g6
again what we talked about before your
game plan isn't always about what you're
doing you always should look about what
your opponent's looking to do now this
move right here does a couple things but
one of the biggest things it does is it
limits the moves where this knight can
go this Knight right here again was
attacking and defending this pawn here
or the square here on you for for this
pawn push but the same time now that
that's already pushed where's this
Knight going to go it can't come to e4
and now I can't come to f5 or h5 so
limiting the squares of your opponent is
a phenomenal tactic that people don't
use as much typically everyone's trying
to look what they can do if you can just
limit all of your opponent's moves it's
going to be very very hard for them to
do anything now from here White's going
to play pawn to f4 really trying to push
forward obviously he does have a queen
and a rook behind it so he kind of knows
if he can break up this pawn structure
his king is completely safe but a black
King is not as safe so he's just going
to start marching up the board here now
black is going to play pawn to f5 he
kind of has to if he just kind of lets
you know that the pawn come to g5 he's
really going to bust it up and it's
going to be a lot harder for him so
instead he plays pawn to f5 now again as
we talked about before white needs to
open
blinds by any means possible so he's
going to he's going to play on pissant
if you're not too familiar you don't
need to write a comment and say Kevin
that's not a that's not a legal move you
can't do that it doesn't capture look it
up it's on pissant it's an actual move
just trust me so the pawn plays pawn to
f6 and captures this pawn here on f5 yes
it is a real move so from here black is
going to play Knight takes on f6 again
he kind of has two and now the pawns
going to start marching up the board
again as you can say he's really
starting to attack all this pawn
structure that black has here now black
is going to play rook to e1 and capture
this rook on e1 any time your opponent
is putting a lot of pressure on you you
want to trade off pieces especially if
you're up in material in this case black
is up in material if you can trade down
all your pieces obviously you're going
to have a much bigger advantage and
especially if he's starting to attack
attack if you can trade down your pieces
he no longer has pieces to attack with
and next thing you know you you're up in
material so that's exactly what
capablanca is looking at he's thinking
you know what my King is pretty safe I
can get my Queen into the action if I
need to but white is really starting to
chip away on my King side safety so I'm
just going to go ahead and start
exchanging pieces here
so from here White's going to obliged
she's going to play rook to e1 and now
the rook is going to come to e8
obviously attacking he's looking to
exchange these these rooks right now he
doesn't mind if the rook comes to e8
because now he can take with his knight
he's up in material and white is going
to have a really hard time with just a
queen here and a knight here to really
do anything obviously was we talked
about this bishop here on b2 is not
doing a whole heck of a lot right now
now the next move from what in my
opinion is what wins the game obviously
black had a questionable move as far as
c4
I don't think that's as bad of a move is
the next move from white is as good if
that made any sense at all but if you
want to go ahead and take a minute and
think about what you think white should
do in this situation and white played
rook
to e6 now this is a phenomenal move
simply because this pawn here on f5 he'd
really like it to be a passed pawn
obviously a passed pawn he's going to
have to be passed all these pawns here
and that would be exactly what would
happen if the route came captured on e6
and then the pawn recaptured on e6 this
is a fantastic pawn it's going to be
really really difficult for black to
stop this pawn marching up the board so
from here black plays exactly that rook
takes on e6 there's really no other good
moves
obviously he obviously is also attacking
this night here on f5 or excuse me f6
let's say the knight tries to come in to
e4 and tries to do something from here
after the White Knight captures on e4
and they trade off then the pawn here
can recapture on g6 and it's going to be
very very difficult
obviously the route can't come and take
on you know e six because then the Queen
can come to f7
this is going to be very very hard you
can see all this defense around the
black King is just falling apart at any
time you know white can take on e8 even
though the Queen's here protecting it's
going to be very very hard for black to
hold on to that was if he takes on e4
obviously he can also come to g4 if he
wants to but from here white can just
play Queen to e2 obviously he's doubling
up on this rook here on eh and at the
same time he's attacking this night here
on g4 so really the only move that Black
has in this situation is to take on e6
which is why rook to e6 in the first
place is such a fantastic move because
now black really has to worry about this
pawn on e6 and keep it keep this in back
your head I told you many times before
but pawns are meant to be pushed
especially if you can get it to that
sixth rank and above you need to push
your pawns so just keep that in the back
your mind white obviously knows this
that's why he's you know a 13 time world
champion he knows this from here black
is going to play King to g7 obviously he
needs to protect his night here on f6
and now White's going to play Queen to
for getting ready to really get his
queen into the action obviously on f2 he
was kind of waiting for something to
happen but this coin here on f4 really
gets his Quinn into involved into the
game and now he can really start to
attack compiz he wants to he can bring
his queen to c7 he can obviously bring
his Queen to e5 if he wants to pinning
down the knight he can also start to get
his knight involved into the game and
really start to attack this King here on
g7 now black finally decides he's like
you know I need to get my queen involved
into the game because white really has a
large attack and I started to try to
trade off pieces and didn't quite work
as I wanted to so white plays a
phenomenal move right here you can pause
it again a lot of analysts look at this
next move and think it's you know an
exclamation point I think it's just you
know pure genius but kind of going off
of what he what he was intending to do
all along and that's to just maintain
pressure obviously you want to put a
very powerful piece behind your pawn
obviously pushing a pawn with nothing
behind it does nothing because they can
just capture it but his next move is
Queen to e5 misses two things again one
it pins down this knight on f6 but at
the same time he can now start to push
this pawn forward and it has a queen
behind it so obviously it's going to be
protected from here Capablanca decides
that he needs to stop the advance of
this pawn here on e6 any time again
Oppong is to the sixth rank you really
really have to start worrying about it
and especially you know if you see this
you know coming for you you just want to
keep pushing forward so from here black
plays Queen to e7 really trying to stop
this again black is up and material so
he just wants to stop white from doing
whatever he's doing and then try to
attack himself so from here white plays
another phenomenal move as he has all
game but he decides to offer up one of
his minor pieces and he plays Bishop to
a3 and all he's looking for is just he's
going to give up three points as far as
material just so he can start to push
this pawn forward which is
I just think fantastic chest but
capablanca decides to go ahead and take
and what a lot of people have noticed in
this game is capablanca took this not
only because it was material but the
same time he kind of felt like he could
just perpetual check the the white King
here if anything you know went wrong
perpetual check is when you just check
over and over and it just ends up in a
draw but why it had other plans and he
decided you know what I've already given
up a bishop let's just go ahead and give
up a night here so he brings his night
to h8 sacrificing another piece here
after he takes on h5 now he brings his
queen to g5 checking the king obviously
the King cannot come to f7 because of
the pawn so he has to move his King back
obviously now we can see that the knight
didn't die you know for no reason he can
now come to f6 and attack the King so he
he didn't lose complete material
obviously he did sacrifice a bishop here
on a3 but now the King comes to g8 and
now what we talked about before pawns
are meant to be pushed
he plays pawn to e7 now keep in mind
this does open the door for black to
start to try to check the king obviously
since black is not in check here he can
start his own attack now as he can't
come and take this pawn on e7 because
then the game would be over he would
just take it they really only hope he
has here this night here on b3 s we
talked about again it's an outpost but
what's it doing it's not doing anything
as we talked about which you know that's
really not how you want your outpost to
do but the same time blacks really hope
is petrol check so the next few moves he
just tries to perpetual check and he
just checks over and over I'm not going
to get into it too much because he just
kind of moves closer and tries to check
the King try to check takes on h5 check
again he moves back tries to check him
come to g4 comes back to e1 and after h5
Capablanca decides hey it's time to give
up I can no longer check the King on
this next move he can come to e8 if he
wants to he can obviously come to f8
with checkmate there's no stay
being white from winning this game so
fantastic game from white one of my
favorite games to study just because
they didn't even have opening theory to
look at they didn't have these huge
engine analysis if they play such
amazing chess and at the same time has a
lot of fundamentals as far as
maintaining center control the board at
the same time pushing pawns and the
power pushing pawns even at the sense of
giving up two of your minor pieces
obviously winning one back right away
but giving up an entire piece just to
move upon one space forward I think
that's phenomenal chess so hopefully you
guys enjoyed this video as much as I did
I'm really enjoying and learning a lot
myself from analyzing these these famous
chess games so I'll leave your comments
let me know what you think please
subscribe to the chess website on
YouTube and if you haven't checked out
the website WWE chess web site calm
thanks and I'll see you next time